my name is Excel Guren I'm head of
autonomous driving here at mercedes-benz
research and develop in North America in
Sunnyvale we started the group three
years ago out of a team of seven people
and we have grown it now up to six teams
I'm really excited to work on that hot
topic we have a very long tradition on
autonomous driving at mercedes-benz
we drove autonomously on the highway
already 20 years ago during the
Prometheus project the latest big
achievement was driving the historic
perturbance route from Mannheim to full
time in 2013
showing that driving and country roads
and inner city traffic is possible we
introduced the stop and go assist in
2013 which allows you to drive semi
autonomous Lee in stop-and-go traffic
and we recently launched the drive pilot
which allows you to drive semi
autonomous lady on on highways so we
take autonomous driving very seriously
and I think we have been really
successful already in that field when
hiring people for the autonomous driving
team we are looking for strong computer
science skills especially programming in
C++ in addition for prototypes we're
using MATLAB and we are using Python for
scripting and deep learning tools
respectively we are looking at a general
good understanding about autonomous
driving and how that works and we are
looking at the solid foundation in terms
of math statistics probabilistic and
algorithms when preparing for the
interview the applicants should brush up
their programming skills
secondly they should think how their
experience and education fits to the job
some applicants are surprised to hear
questions how does an autonomous system
works and so on and people should
prepare that in advance should have an
understanding what's going on in that
fee
and also what Mercedes has already
achieved in that field personally I want
to see the interview from the applicant
that he or she is interested motivated
curious about the topic wants to learn
how it works at Mercedes we have lots of
interns and we are happy to train people
to get the right skills and get
experience in the field we have
employees from all around the world from
China are from India from Germany from
the US from France from Spain from
actually all around the world
I think the nanodegree is a great thing
to get the right experience in that
field so if you have already a really
solid foundation in computer science for
example and you have successfully
achieved the nanodegree you are a pretty
good candidate for first of all I love
the topic so working on autonomous
driving is terrific probably I have the
best job in the world right now working
in Mercedes also is highly motivating
because we can bring autonomous cars to
reality people are coming here because
they are motivated to work on the best
projects in the world I think they are
keen to work on it they are focused on
getting their job done and explore new
ways of solving this really challenging
task of autonomous driving in terms of
teamwork and the culture and the
collaboration it's awesome in here so we
have highly motivated team working
together to solve the problems it's
awesome and I love to come to work every
day if you want to shape the future for
autonomous cars and Mercedes Benz apply
you